tourist is a Russian movie for an
African audience Russian fighters from
the Wagner group are seen helping
African soldiers combat armed groups
shoulder to shoulder for Russia this is
an effort to win hearts and Minds in
country suffering attacks from Al-Qaeda
and isil for France it's Russian
propaganda on a visit to Burkina faso's
capital wagadugu in July the French
general in charge of the
counter-terrorism operation bakan in the
Sahel warned of the dangers of dealing
with the Wagner group
with the arrival of Wagner I see three
threats the rise of mercenaries who are
in real soldiers there is a financial
interest and economy plundering and
there is a campaign of this information
against the action of France not just in
the cycle but beyond its borders in 2018
Al Jazeera met Russian fighters from
Wagner Training soldiers from the
Central African Republic Valerie zakarov
the special advisor to the country's
president told me Russia was back in
Africa since this interview Wagner has
expanded its operation in Mozambique
Sudan the Central African Republic and
Mali
after the coup in Burkina Faso on Friday
the new leadership in wagadugu under
Ibrahim traris says he wants to work
with new partners including Russia
in Western Europe Russia is seen by many
as an adversary its soft power seemingly
eroded by its invasion of Ukraine but in
Western Africa it's seen as a friend an
alternative to the west and France the
former colonial power especially when it
comes to security and Military
cooperation
France continues to have a military
presence in nearly all of its former
African colonies but this hasn't brought
stability to the countries in the Sahel
the French accused the Russians of being
after Burkina fasa's Rich mineral
resources
there has been certain disposition taken
to exploit three gold mines in maliba
Wagner and so the state will have to pay
for the services they are plundering
resources
but in the face of defeat and Military
losses armies in the Sahel including in
Burkina Faso Sea in Russia a military
superpower that can bring Victory on the
battlefield no matter the cost or the
consequences
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera Dakar